bisher konnten nur große oder auch
mittelgroße konzerne strom verkaufen in
zukunft soll das aber jeder können blog
chains machen es möglich also datenblock
hätten ihr könnt euch das vorstellen wie
eine art digitales register dass alle
transaktionen aufzeichnet das hat viele
vorteile beispielsweise ist es für alle
teilnehmer transparent jeder kann
reingucken
mit hilfe von block chains können also
auch privatkunden strom ihrer
solarzellen oder aus den batterien ihrer
elektroautos verkaufen wenn es sich
lohnt wie bald vielleicht jeder mit
strom handeln kann jetzt den klick zum
science and fiction herzlich willkommen
und zum schluss gibt es noch eine kleine
überraschung blog chains kann man quasi
als eine art technische handelsplattform
bezeichnen die die teilnehmer von
transaktionen unabhängiger macht für
viele verschiedene projekte des
nachbarschafts handelt sind dezentrale
blog fans von enormer bedeutung
zum beispiel in der ökostrom szene
normalerweise wird der preis für strom
unter anderem durch die gesetzgebung
netzbetreiber und energieversorger
bestimmt doch blog chains machen es auf
diesem feld jetzt möglich dass
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher selbst
mitmischen wer also eine photovoltaik
anlage auf seinem hausdach hat oder
diejenigen die eine ladesäule in der
garage haben können mit hilfe von block
chains ihre produzierten kilowattstunden
in kapital umwandeln
indem sie ihren strom verkaufen die
programmcodes der block james beinhalten
dabei beispielsweise transaktions
protokolle mit allen möglichen infos
damit die bestellten kilowattstunden
strom an die empfängerin oder den
empfänger transportiert werden können
die daten blöcke sind dezentral
verschlüsselt validiert also auf ihre
gültigkeit überprüft und gespeichert
alle prozesse wie beispielsweise die
buchung oder der erhalt werden in den
daten lockt hätten gespeichert ohne dass
etwas verloren geben kann denn alles ist
transparent und zwar für alle dem
netzwerk sind ein größeres projekt das
beweist dass das technisch funktioniert
läuft dem buckland hier teilen
besitzerinnen und besitzer von
solarstromanlagen ihren strom mit
anderen auch in deutschland ist das
konzept bereits in die praxis umgesetzt
worden die rwe tochter innogy ist an der
idee beteiligt das besitzerinnen und
besitzer von elektroautos ihre ladebox
zu hause teilen kann
damit auch andere strom tanken können
dazu meldet man sich mit einer app an
durch smart contract also auf deutsch
smarte verträge die im programmcode
vorliegen werden die ladebuchse
freigegeben in diesem netzwerk sind
mittlerweile rund 1200 öffentliche und
private ladestation angemeldet und es
funktioniert ungewiss ist allerdings ob
das technisch so klappt wenn es immer
mehr elektroautos geben sollte denn das
bedeutet mehr datendurchsatz denn dann
soll das sogenannte schalding ein wort
konstrukt aus charging laden und sharing
teilen zum einsatz kommt dabei werden
die blöcke nicht mehr im gesamten
netzwerk sondern voneinander getrennten
bruchstücken validiert also auf ihre
echtheit gecheckt auch wenn dieses
konzept große vorteile mit sich bringt
gibt es auch einen schwerwiegenden
nachteil eine studie vom kölner
energiewirtschaftlichen
forschungsinstitut für energy research
und szenarios zeigt jetzt das blog
chains nicht wirtschaftlich sind denn
der preis für den strom wird durch viele
aspekte in die höhe getrieben
beispielsweise durch steuern
einspeisetarife und netzentgelten
nachteilig ist auch dass eine stabile
versorgung nicht gewährleistet werden
kann
denn der netzbetrieb kann sich nicht auf
eine kontinuierliche strohmann lieferung
bzw abnahme einstellen die netzbetreiber
wissen somit nicht wie hoch das angebot
und der bedarf sind doch es gibt
hoffnung eine blockt chain lösung von
ibm soll engpässe im stromnetz
verhindern ihr vorteil sie kann größere
mengen an batterien für den stabilen
netzbetrieb zugänglich machen
die größte herausforderung
branchenübergreifende blog chain
technologien zu optimieren besteht darin
die transaktions rate zu erhöhen bei der
block chain für die krypto währung
bitcoin gegen etwa sieben transaktionen
pro sekunde viel zu wenig nicht nur für
den energiebereich die lösung könnte
eine sogenannte con soziale blog chain
sein hier sind meist unternehmen die
betreiber somit sind die identitäten der
teilnehmer bekannt und damit ist dann
auch das konsens protokoll weniger
aufwendig ist wird deutlich weniger
energie für die block chains benötigt
und bytes werden weniger verstummt 1000
transaktion werden dann tatsächlich pro
sekunde möglich intelligente ladetechnik
wird dann mit den smart contracts
kombiniert die batterien nehmen also
strom auf wenn es zu viel davon gibt
andersherum können sie ihn auch wieder
einspeisen wenn
frage steigt um das angebot zu klein ist
auch das hamburger softwarehaus proton
baut auf eine ähnliche idee enerchange
basiert auf ten dam and eine viel
leistungsfähiger blog chain plattform
wobei in jeder sekunde ein blog gebildet
wird im vergleich bei der smart
kontaktplattform smi um passiert dies
alle 20 sekunden bei der digitalen
währung bitcoin sogar nur alle 10
minuten ein blog fasst mehrere
transaktionen so dass bei optimalen
bedingungen bis zu 10.000 transaktionen
enthalten sein können
ende des jahres wollen unternehmen wie
rwe und total den energiehandel auf
entertain betreiben noch kann man kaum
abschätzen wie sich diese ganzen block
zehn varianten zukünftig gegen zentrale
digitalisierungs techniken werden
experten experten sagen eine
zwischenlösung voraus die zentrale und
dezentrale techniken kombiniert ebenso
genauso wie sich wohl auf die
stromwirtschaft in zukunft aus vielen
kleinen und großen erzeugungs einheiten
zusammensetzen wird auf jeden fall steht
eine revolution des energiemarktes bevor
in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von
technology review ist dieses video
entstanden und speziell für pixum
zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk
ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis
wenn er auf diesen link klickt den
könnte auch gerne weitergeben
technology review ist der absolute
hammer und ja hier geht es zu einem
weiteren video dass wir mit dieser
tollen redaktion zusammen gemacht haben
der verkehr der zukunft vorbild china
klick drauf wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt kann